Philippe Schnobb, président
du conseil d'administration
de la Société de transport
de Montréal.
Bonsoir Philippe.
- Bons
- Vous quittez dans quelques
semaines. Il y a 60 millions de
voitures de plus à Montréal
comme ça reportage, 60 000... 60
000 voitures de plus à
Montréal. Soit million de votre
difficile. Qu'es fait
pour inciter les gens à laisser
la voiture?
est-ce que j'avais réfléchi à
ça?
vous en allais bientôt de plus
souple, plus rapide, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait?
- pluses, c'est la
clé. Ne faut pas dans le
contexte actuel coupé. Il faut
maintenir le service parce que
dans les prochaines années faut
la capacitla capacitla capacitlr
service aux gens qui vont venir.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
service fiable. Je pense que
c'est la clé aussi.
stissement majeur dans le
métro pour s'assurer qu'il n'y a
pas d'arrêt de services liés aux
équipements. Ça c'est important
et dans le but de développer des
réservées. Ce qu'on essaie
de faire Sophie neuf, ça vaouvÇa
être une réalité ce n'est pas
retourné entre deux contre les
édicules. Ça peut être très
utile. Ce ne peut que les gens
sache alors prenutes
le lundi, 10 minutes le mardi
est devenu de mercredi. Dans le
voiturnée 10 minnée 10 minnée 1s
une journée 45 minutes.
- Est-ce que plusieurs trajets
seront beaucoup plus longs
voitures est-ce qu'on n'est pas
condamné avoir toujours plus de
- Un exemple assez particulier.
Mélanie avait dans le vieux
Montréal qui est plus ou moins
esservi. Ça va être mieux
avitailleur à des condos camp de
redressement de Radio-Canada. Il
a une masse critique importante
de gens. Ira de croissance dee e
évidemment. Mais oui, il y a
facteur clé japonaisération sous
comparaisons de trajets. Quand
regarde son gogo, de trajets en
auto ou en transport en commun,
nous ajoutant transport en
commun cette distance de marche.
Quelques minutes pour se rau més
après ça pour se rendre à
destination. Quand on sort du
transport en commun. On ne
en auto. De Gaulle c'est comme
ça le taux de marché soit
quelque pas le temps de
ménagement. On a toujours l'air
désavantagé en transport en
commun.
- Moi, de mon quartier,
l'autobus 124 qui parce que
j'étais plus jeu
ou 30 minutes, p
heure. Si j'ai rendez-vous et le
manque, c'est terminé. Est-ce
qu'on peut dans un contexte de
65 milez
vous augmenter les services dans
les prochaines années?
- Tout à fait. Arrivée trois
Fabrice va nous permettre de
faire ça. On a reçu les sept
trains heures supplémentaires.
Nous permettre et c'est génial
pour ceux qui vont arriver dans
la prochaine, le prochain
groupe. On va voir les outils,
les outils nécessaires pour
prise de contrôle de la suivre.
Pendant des années on est en
retard il faut investir. Là on
mment de bus
pour répondre à la demande qui
va revenir. On va devancer la
demande au lieu d'être à laue.Çs
important. On va voir aussi
capacité parce que on aura un
certain nombre de bus, avoir des
bus en renfort, stationné un peu
partout sur le territoire
pourrait provenir maintenant les
buts sont gérés en temps réel.
Il y a centre de contrôle quisùe
ligne il y a trop de monde,
envoyé envoyait un Bazarova pour
pas un seul voyage et après
ordonner ce stationné pour
né ailleurs. Va faire maintenant
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire
avoir.
- 215 millions, et c'est qui va
arriver après vous être n'est
pas condamné à
service?
- il ne faudrait pas et trouver
des solutions. Je demandais mes
collè
comment fonctionner dans le
contexte?
ailleurs au Québec,
contrairement à ici on est sous
la juridiction de la RTM,
possesseur des surplus d'une
année pour le budget de l'année
suivannomisé
60 millions. Parce qu'on n'a pas
fait d
supplémentaires à l'automne, n'a
pas livré tout le transport
adapté, à la fin de l'année il y
a soit million qui reste sur la
table. On n'a pas pu utiliser en
2021. On est en novembre, on a
40 millions de noms dépensés en
pas l'utiliser
en 2022. La RTM ne nous permet
pas elle garde. Si on avait puit
40 2021 on n'aurait pas de
problème en 2022.
- Mais là vous n'avez alors est-
ce que Québec doit éponger
d'après vous?
- Comment doit faire des effort
SMP ses efforts le Québec l'a
dit, mettre de la mise à jour
budgétaire des éléments. Il faut
regarder plus loin. La pandémie
c'est une chose, la baisselanda,
désolé modèle d'affaires ne
fonctionne pas. N'est pas de la
requérante dans le système pour
toutes dépenses, pandémie ou
pandémie ou non. Ce problème
expert 2019,58 v